hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Caroll as I will mention very briefly in
today's podcast when I was a kid growing
up I knew that I wanted to do science in
fact theoretical physics is what I knew
I wanted to do from a very early age but
theoretical physics you know Einstein's
equation quarks things like that this
was not something anyone in my family or
Circle understood uh they did understand
that it was somehow related to space and
astronomy and things like that so I
would be frequently given you know
telescopes or books about astronomy as
gifts which is great I love that stuff
too it just wasn't what I actually
wanted to do for a living but as a
result of this you know Circa I don't
know 1980 was kind of my Peak knowledge
about modern astronomy even though I
went on as an undergraduate and a
graduate student to be an astronomy
major get a bachelor's degree as well as
a PhD in astronomy by then I was
actually focusing more on learning
fundamental physics so I had to sit
through my required courses in astronomy
but I wasn't like in my spare time
catching up on the most recent
discoveries about planets and stars and
galaxies and stuff like that and even
today you know I just as much as anyone
else follow the news items I get to talk
to my colleagues it's true so I probably
get more inside scoop than the average
person but I'm absolutely not at The
Cutting Edge of what's going on broadly
in astronomy more than many people are
so since I did have that knowledge back
in the 70s and 80s it's always fun to
catch up on what's been going on since
then and when it comes to something like
planets we've just learned so much more
about the planets both in our solar
system as well as exoplanets of course
than we did back then I mean Not only
was Pluto a planet back when I was still
learning this stuff but we had just
started started in the 1970s sending
spacecraft to other planets we had
learned to our surprise that the
atmosphere of Venus was kind of
inhospitable probably we knew that even
before we sent the spacecraft there but
it was a surprise when we learned it we
were still hoping to find Life on Mars
on some of some sort not just little
microbial life but maybe something more
exotic uh the very first Landers the
Viking Landers were sent to Mars but
also they were missions sent to Venus
that just plunged right in even missions
sent to Mercury as well as of course
famously the Pioneer and Voyager
missions to the outer planets so it was
very exciting time back then but so much
more has happened now landing on all
sorts of planets investigating them
measuring their properties with much
greater Precision so today we have to
catch up on some of this knowledge with
Sabina stanlee who is actually an
astronomer at Johns Hopkins and has
recently come out with a book published
by John hop John Hopkins University
press called what's hidden inside
planets and the idea is of course that
there is the atmosphere and the outer
layers of planets but there's also the
very fun Interiors of planets which is
kind of a place where we know a lot but
much less than we would like to even the
Earth as we will learn in the podcast we
know things indirectly not directly we
have not journeyed to the Center of the
Earth in reality as much as we like to
imagine doing so in fiction so it's
always fun to learn how clever
scientists have been to figure out
what's going on in places we can't see
including the ground right beneath our
feet and extending that knowledge then
to other planets making predictions for
what their gravitational fields should
be what their magnetic fields should be
watching those predictions go wildly
wrong updating our models and going oh
yes we forgot about sulfur that's kind
of important or something like that so
there's a whole mess of things we're
going to going to learn we're going to
learn about the diamond Iceberg floating
on liquid oceans in cold planets far
away and how all that stuff happens and
how much more we have yet to learn so
let's
[Music]
go SAA stand the welcome to the
mindscape podcast thanks so much for
having me so we're going to talk about
what's inside planets I wanted to set
the stage just by remembering you know
when I was a kid we had terrestrial
planets and we had gas giants right and
of course these days you know we kick
Pluto out and we've discovered
exoplanets and things like that is it
still though basically true that we have
those two categories or has our space of
possible planets to think about grown
bigger I definitely think the space of
possible planets has grown bigger right
even in our own solar system we even now
with the giant planets we know that
there's you know there's Jupiter and
Saturn which are these gassy giant
planets then you've got the icer planets
Uranus and Neptune so they can be quite
different we have metal worlds in our
solar system with h 16 psyche this
asteroid that the psyche mission is
going to go to as well so there there's
a lot of variety even here in our solar
system and everything we've found
outside of our solar system just shows
us how many more possibilities there are
well my not quite expert um impression
from the exoplanet research is that we
have been surprised by various
properties of planets have we actually
discovered new kinds of
planets yeah absolutely it's really
interesting to think about you know I
remember when I was learning this stuff
in in undergrad that we had this sort of
real belief that we understood how
planets formed and that wherever we
would look it should be that you'd have
the rocky planets in kind of the closer
to the star system and then you'd have
the gas giant planet further out and
then boom the first exoplanets we see
suddenly you've got something bigger
than Jupiter um orbiting closer than
Mercury does in our own solar system so
uh this early exoplanet discoveries just
really showed us that we needed to kind
of rethink how Planet formation occurs
and and what the possibilities are out
there and I guess it it made sense to
think that back in the day right because
we thought that the in the early stages
of the formation of the planetary system
the atmosphere would get blown off of
the planets I mean that's my again I'm a
very theoretical physicist here but I
have this feeling that you know the
inner planets are rocky because that's
all that was left and the outer planets
are gaseous because they could keep
their
atmospheres it's it's a little bit I
would say it's a little bit different
it's more that the inner planets are
rocky because there was no gas they
couldn't grow fast enough to collect the
gas whereas the outer planets could grow
faster because they had more building
blocks but I think the key thing that we
learned from looking at these exoplanet
systems is there was a process that we
had kind of thought wasn't that
important for our own solar system but
turns out to be important in other solar
systems and that's planetary migration
the fact that planets can move their
orbits over time well I will we can jump
around we don't need to be uh logical
order here for what we're talking about
so I'll confess when I was you know
looking into your book and and thinking
about this podcast I never knew that
people thought that Jupiter might have
started its life much much closer to the
Sun than it is now yeah it's possible
that it actually moved a lot it started
further out then came in kind of closer
to kind of where Mars currently is and
then switched again and started moving
out again and Urus and Neptune might
have actually switched places it used to
be that Neptune was closer than Urus so
these are all reasonable possibilities
based on what we see in terms of the
orbits of a lot of the asteroids and
Kyper objects out there in the outer
solar system system right now is there
some just human scale difficulty because
when we see the solar system it seems
like more or less the same from when
we're born to when we die and
extrapolating it back a billion years is
kind of hard yeah I think that's a
natural issue that we always have with
things that are on such long time scales
are really far away is is putting it on
the scale but I was even I I know this
is kind of in a separate vein but I
think it's interesting to think about
the fact that it's possible that Saturn
didn't have rings when they were
dinosaurs on earth so things do change
right even in sort of the time scales
we're used to trying to comprehend even
if it's not on a human lifestyle a life
lifespan time scale so let me just
quickly get your opinion did do you do
you think Saturn did have rings back
when the dinosaurs were around oh gosh I
I think it's not something to have an
opinion about I think it's really
interesting to think about how the Rings
are populated and and how they change
and I think we just need more data to
study that and what is your okay here is
an opinion question Pluto planet or
not okay here's the here's my answer
it's not a planet and that's
okay Pluto is just really cool it was
such an interesting object that it
started its own class of planetary
object the dwarf planet so why would you
want to be a planet when you can just
start your own class of planetary object
so you know I will I will confess I've
said this before but uh in the early
days was against kicking Pluto out of
the planet Club on the basis of you know
the idea of a planet is something we
human beings made up we can grandfather
in Pluto but I had Mike Brown who was a
good friend of mine from Caltech on the
podcast and I read his book and I did
change my mind like a good scientist
should so I think that the scientists
are right about this one I agree okay so
let's get to what you actually do for
living as I understand it the Interiors
of planets which is a little bit harder
than the exteriors right we can't
actually see them I presume we start by
thinking about the Earth and what we
know about its
interior yeah absolutely you know it's
frustrating because when you try to
think about what's going on inside a
planet your first instinct is you know
let's let's dig in there and get some
samples and try and figure that out but
it's just it's impossible for earth
right the furthest we've ever drilled
into the planet is under 10 kilometers
right it's it's basically nothing under
10 miles sorry it's basically nothing
for a planet with uh say 6,000 k radius
right so we're just kind of getting at
the skin here so we have to be really
sneaky and and clever in how we figure
out properties of the interior of the
planet do a lot of things that like
doctors do to figure out what's wrong
with you when you go to the doctor ride
hopefully they don't drill first and
kind of figure out things that later
right so uh it's a lot of honing
techniques to give us the information
we're looking for for the Interiors of
Planet I it's kind of sad that we've
only gone down 10 less than 10 miles um
is that a ambition the planetary
scientists have like you know like
particle physicists want to build a
bigger and bigger collider do planetary
physics want to dig deeper and
deeper I don't think it's so much
nowadays that there's this goal of
digging we want to learn more and more
about the Deep interior but we're open
to the fact that there are better
sometimes more efficient other ways to
do this right so nowadays I think we
rely a lot on the combination of um
sort of non digging type technology
right relying on sensors and and waves
to study the interior but also the fact
that we can get S samples can come up
from depth um whenever diamonds come to
the surface some of them actually
preserve bits of the mantle in their
inside of them in their like as
inclusions and so we can learn about
things that way meteorites tell us about
the Interiors of asteroids and other
bodies out there so so we're willing to
get the information however possible I'm
not sure that we're all kind of um
hellbent on digging anymore well uh I'm
sorry just to follow up on this crazy
scenario but if I did want to build a
little robot that had a drill and could
just dig down deeper and deeper what is
the obstacle is it the Heat or the
density or the power source so it's a
combination of the pressure and the heat
right uh every time you you're going a
little bit deeper inside the planet
temperatures are rising equipment
doesn't like hot temperatures doesn't
like high pressure press doesn't humans
don't like them so it's harder to get
down there to fix things as well just as
it is if you're going out into space so
it's the combination right if you think
about sort of the deepest Minds we have
that humans can function in right you're
talking about things that are in the two
mile depth range one to two mile depth
range right so it's a combination of
those two issues okay so we're stuck
with uh being the doctor who cannot
perform surgery um what do we actually
do how do we know about I guess maybe
what is the Earth interior like and then
how do we know yeah so the Earth which
is kind of a good prototype or typical
example of a rocky planet the outer part
of it is made of sort of magnesium
silicates what we would normally
consider as Rocky materials and then the
inner part of the planet is uh iron so
we have an iron core in Earth the
innermost part of that about the the
innermost 1300 km is solid and then
you've got a liquid iron core for
another 2,000 or so
uh and so you've got this separation
right the heaviest stuff the densest
stuff is at the center um and then the
outer layers are rock and that's true
for the other rocky planets as well so
how do we figure this all out uh
combination of of methods uh one of the
coolest methods to me to talk about the
one that gives us a lot of information
is seismology so every time there's an
earthquake somewhere uh waves sound
waves essentially travel through the
Earth and we can record when they arrive
at different locations on on the surface
and those waves whatever region they
travel through the speed of the wave is
completely related to the material
properties that they're traveling
through so we can use that information
at the surface and kind of backtrack all
the waves that go through the Earth and
learn about the material they pass
through that's how we learned that the
Earth has an iron core that the outer
part of it is liquid um we can learn
about phace transitions in the Earth's
mantle so when minerals change their
structural um properties into other
physical Arrangements um all sorts of
stuff so that's kind of been the the
sort of work Workhorse of planetary
interior
studies obviously you know I've heard
that story before and does make sense
right you have a soundwave traveling
through and it's kind of it is kind of
like what doctors do whether it's a CAT
scan or an MRI or whatever but exactly
but it still seems a little crude you
know I mean hearing these sounds from
earthquakes thousands of miles away and
saying okay I have now inferred the
internal structure of the earth I mean
what's our confidence level here so
here's the amazing things uh we have
lots of earthquakes they travel through
different parts of the earth they travel
in different directions through
different materials so with sort of
modern day analysis techniques and uh
computational methods we can actually
get a lot of really great data we can
see things like um volcanic plumes
coming up from the corental boundary all
the way uh to the surface of the Earth
we can see subducting slabs so places on
the planet where one tectonic plate is
descending back into the Earth under
another one we can see that colder
material descending into the earth
almost all the way down to the cor manal
boundary so we're really at the point
where we're getting like lateral
structure we're getting it's not just a
depth as a fun or density as a function
of depth it's really like Imaging now of
the Interior so we're getting a
something like a 3D picture of what the
Earth's interior looks like
absolutely and okay so we have the core
the inner core and outer core and mantle
are the three that I remember from high
school yeah that that's still true like
everything else I learned in my high
school science classes is not true
anymore it's still true it's just it
gets more the more we learn the more we
can break things up right now the
Mantle's got the upper mantle the lower
mantle you can talk about transition
zones you can talk about all fun sorts
of phase transition stuff like that but
to a basic level that's still accurate
and which parts are liquid and which
part part are solid so the only liquid
part in the interior of the earth is the
liquid iron outer core so there's about
22500 kilometers or so um near the
center of the earth that's
liquid so the very core is also iron but
solid yeah that is correct and there's
an interesting property in uh in the
Deep Interiors is that so pressure is
increasing as you're going deeper and
temperature is increasing as you're
going deeper so the very center of the
earth even though the temperature is
much hotter than the outer parts of the
layers it's solid because it's pressure
Frozen it's basically squeezed so much
that it has to be solid so uh just a fun
thing when you're thinking about how
things are different inside the earth
than they are say at the surface and the
mantle I guess this is part of my inner
picture which is probably faulty but I
think of it as what's coming up in lava
in volcanoes and things like that which
looks liquid to me but it's actually
solid so yeah here's this is such a
common understanding that's that needs
to be corrected right we when we see it
at the surface yes lava is liquid but
that's because you took something that
was under really high pressure and you
quickly depressurized it right so that
material that's coming up at volcano it
wasn't liquid inside the earth it was
solid it just got deep pressurized so
that then that expanded volume made it
into a liquid okay but the um you know
the Earth is 4 something billion years
old is should we be surprised that it's
as active as it is that it's still sort
of turning around and plate tectonics
and all that stuff why hasn't it settled
down yet that's a great question so yes
the Earth is very old uh it all the
planets are but all the planets we have
some hints of some sort of activity on
the inside we're the only planet with PL
tectonics but you got Mercury's
generating a Dynamo in its core which
means that its core is still convecting
and very active you have tectonic
processes happening on Mars so the crust
in the the outer parts of the planets
are shifting around in response to like
they're flexing in response to say
thermal gradients or other tidal forces
and stuff like that uh the key thing
with planets is all planets start out
really hot the centers of planets are
much hotter than the space and so
they're all Cooling and most of the
Motions most of the processes we see
happening are a result of that cooling
uh and so that activity is the cooling
and it takes a really long time to cool
down a planet so that's why we're still
seeing activity everywhere and part of
that is that these Interiors are not
only iron they have heavier radioactive
elements that are still providing some
heat that's exactly right so you've got
the initial heat of formation when these
planets formed they stored a lot of heat
inside but planets also have uranium
thorium these long lived radi nucleid
that can actually generate heat today
about half of the heat coming out of the
Earth today is coming from radioactive
elements in Earth's mantle that always
you know again my my intuition fails me
here right because there's not that much
uranium and Thorium in there uh but I
guess there's a lot of volume in the
earth so it's enough to keep it hot
exactly and how do we know how much
uranium is in the middle of the earth is
it is it reverse engineering from how
hot it is no it's actually based on so
if we look at samples that we have of
Earth Mo so it's mostly based on
estimates we have from the crust or
maybe the upper mantle you take samples
from there you actually uh measure how
much your uranium and thorium or their
daughter products that you have there
and from that you come up with estimates
of what you think is in your It's a
combination of just direct measuring and
then also understanding okay so I've got
a rock and um when it melts does uranium
and thorium prefer to be with this part
of the Melt or that part of the Melt so
it's a lot of geology and geochemistry
involved that can tell you where you
should expect to find the uranium dor
yeah it it's always a reminder to me
because uh as a physicist I will
sometimes teach general relativity and
it's this beautiful pristine logical
edifice right and and I love teaching it
and then sometimes I'll teach cosmology
and it's a mess like every week you have
to do something else like thermodynamics
and enm and whatever particle physics I
imagine that your job is even more of a
mess than cosmology is in terms of all
the different kinds of knowledge that
come in yeah absolutely but honestly
that's what I love about it I love the
fact that in order to make uh to have
progress in understanding the interior
of the earth and planets you need to
combine the the sort of fundament Al
physics knowledge the chemistry
knowledge the methods and like sensors
and uh observational methods knowledge
right it's it's a big puzzle and you got
to bring in all these different types of
knowledge to get an answer speaking of
which okay we talked about the uh
seismic information I guess I should ask
is there is that more active or passive
like do we have detectors that were set
up specifically to understand the
interior of the Earth or do we sort of
piggyback off of the that we want to
know where earthquakes are happening
anyway so over time it there's been more
and more uh interest in having seismic
Sensers sensors basically all over the
surface of the Earth and there are these
great sort of dense arrays of sensors
for example all over the US there's this
moving us sensor Network that goes
around and other countries and regions
of the Earth are doing this as well um
so we're very actively looking for um
putting up sensors so that we can
measure when earthquakes happen uh where
they are uh we are also kind of moving
out into the solar system right we we
have had seismometers on the moon since
the Apollo missions uh they were turned
off in the I guess it was the early 80s
uh but we've very recently put a
seismometer on Mars and been able to
measure Mars Quakes there and from that
in from those Mars Quakes be able to
learn about the interior of Mars as well
so I think there's a major move to using
seismology on other planetary bodies
because of the wealth of information it
provides cool and I guess probably there
wasn't a lot on the moon or are there
moonquakes all the time there are
moonquakes all the time so this is
amazing so uh and a lot of the Artemis
Mission there are plans to to f put new
seismometers on the moon in different
locations so that we can start studying
these again uh Moon Quakes actually
happen for a variety of reasons uh
sometimes you have impact so the Moon is
hit with metors as well as Earth is and
all other planets over time so we can
measure Moon Quakes from that but there
are also these very deep moonquakes they
happen much deeper in the moon and
they're actually caused by tidal flexing
of the moon so the moon experiences
tidal forces just like the Earth does
why we have Tides moon has tides and so
we can actually measure uh Rumblings in
the inside of the Moon from those uh
tital forces all right and then what
else besides seismic information do we
use to learn about the interior of the
Earth yeah so then take a combination of
uh Fields so gravity Fields magnetic
fields those are probably the biggest
ones there so gravity Fields the fact
that um you know when when we teach our
intro physics courses we tell everyone
you know G is 9.8 me per second Square
on the surface of the Earth that's not
true as you walk around on the surface
of the Earth the value of G actually
varies and it depends on how much masses
directly below you and so we can measure
those variations in gravity and use that
to actually learn about variations in
density below our feet and so we can do
this for other planets as well there
have been gravity missions sent to uh
well basically any planet that we've
sent a mission to we have gravity data
from okay uh and from that we can learn
about the interior Mass distributions
inside planets you know in cosmology
right now there's a famous Hubble
tension we measure the Hubble constant
two different ways and get two different
answers I could imagine uh a Earth's
core tension if you measured its
properties seismically one way and then
magnetic fields or gravitational fields
in other way is there any such thing on
the horizon or is everything completely
compatible it's that's an interesting
question first of all I'm frustrated
with the even though I'm not in the
field I hate that it's called attention
because I'm like it's not attention it's
a
complete like it's a disagreement
difference completely different numbers
that's not attention but anyway going
back to the earth I think it's much more
that the methods are very complimentary
so gravity tells you something about
bulk stuff right the gravity field can't
really tell you about what the density
is at a particular location but you
combine that with the seismology and the
seismology tells you hell hey you have
an iron core at the center then that you
combine that with the gravity and you
can use that to really infer more
details about stuff right so all the
methods are really complimentary there
isn't any tension that I can think of
offand there are actually there the the
latest tension that's
interesting is with what seismology and
gravity are telling us for example about
Mar what Mars's core is made of and what
we think is true about um the material
that was around in the solar system all
planets were forming so in Mars Insight
mission right measures the radius of the
core for the first time very near the
end of the mission we were waiting for
like the big one on Mars and it finally
came like a couple months before we were
shutting down the mission and from that
we were able to figure out the radius of
Mars's core and it's a little bit bigger
than we thought we knew from Gravity but
gravity tells you a bulk measurement so
essentially if the core is bigger it may
means that it has to be a little less
dense a little lighter than what we
thought but if it's a little lighter
that means that combined with the iron
in the core there's some lighter
elements and it's really hard to kind of
figure out how these Light Elements got
to the center of Mars um based on what
we thought the building blocks of
planets were so that's kind of a little
bit of a tension right now although I
think there are ways around it we just
need to understand the geoc Ministry of
Planet formation a little more I think
the better thing for you to do is to
label it the Mars core crisis and the
grand money and the publicity will start
rolling in I I will take that advice
that's amazing and you mentioned
something a little provocative before
about Mercury and convection and
magnetic fields so magnetic fields are
obviously the other way as you you
mentioned gravity and and magnetism what
does the Earth's magnetic field let us
infer about its interior yeah great
question so magnetic fields happen to be
my favorite thing to talk about and you
can learn a lot from magnetic fields for
any Planet so let's start with Earth uh
the key thing about magnetic fields if a
planet has a magnetic field then first
of all you know it has to have a good
electrical conductor somewhere on the
inside and that's great iron at the
center of the earth does that for you um
you know it has to have motions in it
and so that tells you that first of all
you have to have a liquid to have the
Motions be fast enough for this to occur
and there needs to be a power source for
those motions and so this is how we know
for example that Earth's core there's
convection going on in Earth's core it's
trying to remove heat um through that
convection and so that tells us a lot
about how much energy and power is
stored inside the earth so tell you you
learn a lot about the thermal Evolution
um of a planet by knowing that it has an
active magnetic field generator today it
gets generated by this Dynamo action
right similar sort of process that runs
your generators or your bike lights um
but lots of information by seeing a
magnetic field so the convection is
presumably in that liquid outer core
absolutely and it really is just sort of
a constant turning because of thermal
disequilibrium somehow so yeah basically
it's like when you put a pot on your
stove Bottom's hotter than the Top If
you um try to get heat through there
faster than can be conducted through the
material you're going to get convection
so it's the same sort of thing inside
the core of a planet and that so if it
in the absence of that if you didn't
have that you would not have a magnetic
field there's no way that's correct yeah
that is correct so uh for example Mars
today doesn't have an actively
generating magnetic field today doesn't
have a Dynamo but it does have rocks on
the surface that are magnetized which
tells us that it did have a Dynamo in
its past so we've learned something
about the thermal evolution of Mars four
billion years ago by looking at these
rocks on the surface that are magnetized
but there's no convection going on in my
refrigerator
magnets so that's a different kind of
magnet so when you have per perent
magnets so the insides of planets aren't
permanent magnets these are what are
called induction processes creating
magnetic field so it's the moving around
of currents that are creating new
magnetic fields it's not like permanent
magnets like your fridge right magnet
good and so that does sound like a
pretty consistent story overall like if
we didn't know about the magnetic field
would the seismic observations have led
us to conclude that part of the core was
Liquid so yes so the seismic
observations luckily can give us that
information a completely different way
it's because a certain type of wave
doesn't travel through liquids so these
sheer waves that are called S waves
inside planets they don't travel through
liquids so when we see them disappear in
our seismic records we say ah there must
they must have gone through a liquid um
but what magnetic fields can add to it
is is first of all the Motions we can't
tell that there are motions in the core
um without magnetic fields and the other
thing that magnetic fields can really do
for you is tell you about the history of
a planet so because the rocks on the
surface were cord magnetic fields at the
time they form that's why we learned
about plate tectonics on the surface of
the Earth and where the land masses were
in the past and so forth and exact same
sort of thing on Mars we could learn
that the core of Mars is liquid from
seismology but we never would have been
able to learn um that it had a Dynamo in
its early history if it weren't for
magnetic fields being recorded in the
rocks and the magnetic field of the
Earth does all these weird things like
it wanders around occasionally it just
reverses its polarity right and as far
as I know we can't predict when and
we're not exactly sure why yeah that's a
great great way of looking at it so it's
it's an interesting um comparison when
you think about the Sun so our sun also
is a magnetic field and that magnetic
field also reverses but it does so like
clockwork every 11 years poof reversal
right in the earth we're aware of
reversals because we have Rock record
that tells us that there are reversals
in the past but it's not periodic um but
it's happened if you were to take all
the ones we know about and divide by the
amount of time they've happened over on
average every half million years or so
the Earth's magnetic field reversals um
the last reversal was about 750,000
years ago so in some Metric we're a
little bit overdue for a reversal but
it's also you know a kind of non
non-periodic process so it could just be
normal right now it could be another
quarter million years before it happen
exactly would it be bad if it happened
tomorrow would like break the
Internet it's interesting question uh as
far as we know again having not Liv
through a reversal ourselves and be able
to measure it what we can see in the
Rock riger tells us first of all that
reversals probably take a bit of time
they might take somewhere on the order
of a thousand years or so to actually
fully complete so I like to hope that as
humans any of the complications
associated with a reversal we could
actually um adjust for right so the main
issues we would have if a reversal
occurs is actually due to our technology
right so we rely very heavily right now
on uh satell light orbiting the Earth
they do everything for from GPS to
navigation to all that stuff right uh
our magnetic field actually very much
Shields all of those satellites from the
high energy particles that come from the
Sun the solar wind and and cosmic rays
so during a reversal the Earth magnetic
field actually um decreases somewhat
gets more chaotic and so satellites in
orbit would actually be more um
susceptible to being hit by these high
energy uh cosmic rays and and solar wind
and so they're they could get knocked
out for example so
but you know if that happens on say a
human life time scale hopefully we could
change our technology in time to deal
with that I do remember reading that the
over the last 150 years the magnetic
field has been diminishing slightly in
magnitude yeah slightly that's true but
it's interesting if you look at a longer
time record it was actually pretty high
recently so the diminishing that's
happening now is still putting us above
the average over say the past 10,000
years so I think we have to look at a
longer time record before we can decide
is this some weird anomaly are we in the
beginning of a reversal or not for for
the young people out there who are
deciding on their future research
careers uh is understanding the Earth's
magnetic field something that is still
very much an ongoing project absolutely
so there and there's different ways you
can tackle this right so there for
people who really like sort of studying
fluid dynamics and sort of nonlinear
Dynamics chaos that kind of stuff
there's understanding of the fundamental
um process involved for people who
really like observational studies um
trying to get data now from satellites
in orbit uh lots of cool data analysis
projects we're really trying to
understand the magnetosphere the region
surrounding Earth because that's
important for understanding of space
weather and and that helps us in keeping
our technology going and then of course
for other planets we're trying to learn
about them from their magnetic Shields
as well so yeah there's lots of work to
be done here it's a very data driven
field lots of um use nowadays of you
know uh data science machine learning uh
High computational models lots of the
cool stuff going on and and something
you're implying is that both the plate
tectonics on earth and the magnetic
field are kind of temporary I mean
eventually those radioactive materials
will Decay away and the Earth will just
cool off that is yes that is accurate
all right so we should enjoy the
magnetic field while we we have it yes
absolutely maybe we'll find new ways to
generate it or something that's yeah the
other thing that makes the Earth special
here in the solar system is the moon
right I mean the Moon is much bigger to
the Earth than any other planet
satellite is do we
learn about the Earth by studying the
moon or vice versa or is there still a
lot of uncertainty about how the whole
thing came together in the first place
absolutely so it's really interesting to
me that especially if you're thinking
about the early history of earth right
you had mentioned Earth
4.67 so billion years old and the
surface of the Earth is very young
because we have PL tectonics the surface
gets recycled back into the interior
there's very little old rock on the
surface fortunately for us there's lots
of old rock on the Moon and the Earth
and the moon formed from the same sort
of material there was a giant impact
very early in in Earth's history and so
there's a lot of similarities between
the Earth's material and and the moon's
material and so and being able to look
at the Rock record on the moon actually
tells us a lot about first of all the
early solar system in general but also
about the earlier is that impact Theory
more or less the Consensus These Days
yeah it's it's the only one that can
explain all the observables at the
moment I I read that there was recently
a story a claim that we could so if
there was an impact then there was the
Proto Earth and some other planet the
planet has a name that I forget now came
and smashed into us and we can actually
identify chunks of the planet inside the
Earth right now is that credible so uh
my understanding of that research is
that we do computer simul ation of that
impact noway so you take a body that was
a mars-sized body believed to be it's
usually given the name the and when it
crashed into the Earth you can ask the
question where did the material go and
you do find that some of the material
from the impactor uh gets put inside the
earth and so the question is does it mix
in all the way or or so forth and there
have been some computer simulations of
these processes that suggest that this
some of it ends up at the bottom of the
mantle kind of right above the core
mantle boundary and it turns out that we
have these weird features in the mantle
that we've learned from seismology that
are down there and so I would put it at
the moment as a as a hypothesis with
some simulation suggesting it's feasible
but there are potential other
explanations for the materials that we
see down at the core menal batteries so
it's not definitive I would say at the
moment but should we get the impression
that the
simple cartoon that we see of the
Cutaway Earth with the inner core outer
core mantle there the reality is not
quite so pretty and symmetric as that
yeah that's definitely true right it's
never as pretty as as the simple
models and also the movie The Core was
probably not realistic the movie The
Core is my favorite movie in the whole
universe first off but it is accurate to
say that there are some things in it
that are not realistic but still a a
great some of the some of the stuff in
there was F fabulous that you you got to
take what you can get for Hollywood
entertainment that's fine okay so I mean
with the moon what do we know about its
interior you said there are moon Quakes
does it also have a a hot little core so
the moon does have a core but the core
is much smaller than for example earth's
core is relative to the size of Earth so
the moon's core is only about 400
kilometers in radius right the moon's
radius is about 1,800 or well crap what
is it the moon's radius yeah it's about
1,800 kilm 1700 kilometers or so they
can look that up don't worry yeah yeah
so we'll Google that later so it's a
smaller core uh and that actually makes
sense when we think about how the moon
formed because the Collision that would
have created the moon um when you do a
glancing impact probably the core of the
Moon of that seya body ended up more
inside the earth and more Rocky material
from Earth's mantle and from Thea ended
up in orbit around Earth and that then
created the moon so it's it's it makes
sense that there's less iron in the moon
uh if it formed from that impact and it
also sometimes I when things make sense
that I'm I think I understand them but
but I really don't so it sounds like it
makes sense that the moon uh is cooler
on the inside and doesn't have a
magnetic field and doesn't have plate
tectonics just because it's smaller in
addition to the formation history you
mean it should cool off quicker right so
this is interesting yes it makes sense
that way uh however we have to be very
careful with reasoning like that and
there's a great story about the planet
Mercury when we do reasoning like that
so uh the first mission that went to
Mercury to study the planet in in detail
was Mariner 10 in the mid 1970s and
there's this great paper that came out a
couple years before the uh spacecraft
got to Mercury and it said Mercury is a
very small planet which is true and so
it should cool down fast which is true
and so it shouldn't have an active
Dynamo generating magnetic field today
because the core should be completely
solidified and then boom Mariner 10 gets
to Mercury and measures an active
magnetic field and so
luckily right and and that's okay
predictions are are you know meant to be
there as based on what our understanding
of the theory is at the time um but
after we actually saw the magnetic field
then scientists went back to the drawing
board and they were like okay maybe the
core is not pure iron mix in a little
bit of sulfur in that iron and you
changed the melting temperature so much
that you could actually keep the core
liquid much longer and so it was just it
was this actual data I guess what I'm
trying to say is data is really
important before we um use sort of just
very basic principles to try and
understand what's going on inside a
planet the details tend to matter a lot
are we lucky that Mariner was equipped
with a
magnetometer uh yes because there was no
other way to know that uh from that it
was not until much later um just before
the messenger Mission got to Mercury in
the early 2000s that we actually had
another way to determine that there was
a liquid core inside Mercury and that
was from a really interesting study of
radar observations from Earth um looking
at Mercury and seeing how the planet
wobbles while it spins okay and so
because mercury has this very elliptical
orbit around the sun uh it's length of
day essentially changes a little bit
depending on how far it is from the Sun
and we could actually measure that
wobble and from that get the moment of
inertia and from that realize that the
the the amount that the planet was
wobbling meant there had to be a liquid
layer decoupling the outer part of the
planet from the interior part and so we
didn't get that information until the
early 2000s but it again confirmed what
the magnetic field was already telling
us that there must be a liquid iron core
inside Mercury here's how much astronomy
I've forgotten uh is mercury totally
locked is it the
same Mercury is in this three to2 yeah
okay thin orbit locking so it's not
purely talot so it's not that one uh
face faces the sun all the time so one
year doesn't equal one days instead it's
the 3:2 ratio okay so the but that's a
very nice thing for the observations of
Wiggles and so forth we can figure out
what they should be what they are okay
good all right well so then um should we
be a little shrined that our theorists
didn't predict something like that ahead
of time like how how good is the
state-of-the-art of of we
astrophysicists being able to say here
is what planet formation was like and
therefore what planets should be like I
like to think of it as I think what
we're learning is that the details
really matter and so so you need to
understand very specific details of a
planet or a situation in order to
understand what to expect and that also
means that more and more data actually
really helps us every time we send a
mission to a planet we basically rewrite
the textbooks about that what we know
about that planet right um we aren't
just refining sort of a a number or a
very specific Theory we're actually
having to be very creative and coming up
with new explanations for phenomena we
see whenever we go to a planet now so
let's just like run through the
managerie
uh I guess we have the four in planets
they're all terrestrial but they're all
also kind of different which is weird
and fun and how well do we well how are
they different and how well do we
understand why yeah great question so I
think this is something that actually I
think we need to be very careful about
when we're especially thinking about
exoplanets nowadays is that I would
argue that the reason the four innermost
planets are so different is because of
really
tiny circumstances essentially um
Mercury why is it so tiny and have such
a huge iron core probably because it got
hit by a giant impactor very early on
its history so that one giant impact
completely changed the history of that
body right um Venus and Earth so similar
in terms of fundamental properties mass
and radius so different in terms of
living environment on the surface and
that's likely because Venus just a
little bit closer to the Sun so it's a
little bit hotter and went through this
runaway greenhouse process right again a
tiny detail a few degrees in tempature
difference right Mars uh lots of
planetary formation models when they try
to create the inner solar system they
cannot make a small Mars Mars is
supposed to be big um the problem is
though uh what we think is the reason
for that is because if you include the
outer planets Jupiter ends up disrupting
a lot of Planet formation in the Mars
region and so it's hard to build a big
planet where Mars is uh so again depends
on what was near you what did you have a
Jupiter planet just outside of you so
there lots of like individual
circumstances with each planetary body
that ultimately determines its Evolution
so I I think that's really important to
think about when for example we're
looking at exoplanets and thinking about
is there life out there what makes a
habitable planet well maybe it's not
just about the distance from the Sun or
star and the radiation environment
there're they're going to be very
specific details that determine whether
a planet is actually habitable a lot of
history in a lot of probabilistic events
exactly exactly and so Venus and Mars uh
are not that different in size from the
earth they're slightly different
distances from the Sun like you said but
are their Interiors comparable in some
way so both so Earth Venus and Mars are
all roughly the same in terms of them
having half their radius be about iron
and the other half be Rock so in that
sense their Interiors are very similar
on a basic level yeah Mercury is the
outlier there and that it's mostly iron
very Little Rock but we think we
understand that from a giant
impact how do we know about the interior
of Venus we cannot go down to the
surface and do seismology so V so this
is I go about this go on about this in
my book a little bit Venus is very
frustrating right it's the worst planet
on the out there it's right there it's
the closest planet yeah it's right there
uh but as planetary scientists we've
developed all these methods to study the
Interiors of planets and almost every
single one of them fails when it comes
to Venus because of some reason or
another right Venus doesn't have an
active Dynamo today generating magnetic
field so we can't use magn information
to learn about its interior um it
rotates so slowly that it's really hard
to use um information we can get from
the shape of a planet so for example the
Earth is a little bit bulgy right it's
equator is wider than its pole to- Poole
region all the planets are bulgy because
they're rotating Venus rotates so slowly
that you can't really tell about uh how
bulge the Bulge doesn't tell you a lot
of information about the interior
whereas because of the gravitational
effects of it when we look at the Bulge
of another planet the shape of another
planet we can actually say something
about the density in its interior uh
Venus you know you want to put a
seismometer on Venus sure except it has
to live in a completely hostile
environment and it would basically melt
right away and um if no one can go down
there because of the toxic atmosphere so
we can't use seismology to study Venus
either right so every all these
wonderful ways we we've can found to
discover the what's going on inside a
planet just fail when you get to Venus
so it's very frustrating but we are
making progress I don't to make it sound
impossible um there have been very
recent papers where people have been
measuring kind of the slow rotation and
a little bit about the procession rate
of Venus to learn about what's going on
um inside the planet um and hopefully
the new missions that will hopefully go
to Venus will learn even more I mean if
an advanced alien civilization wanted to
hide out in the solar system from us the
surface of Venus would be a great place
to do it right yeah if they can survive
there absolutely well they're an
advanced alien civilization
uh but nevertheless we do think that
thei is similar is there I mean or maybe
there's no liquid part to the core
because there's no magnetic field so
that's interesting so we don't know for
sure but we do think that the core of
Venus is probably liquid it's probably
just not experiencing the Motions the
convective Motions that we have inside
the earth to create a magnetic field
okay and that might be because of the
fact that um it's not cooling fast
enough to get convection to happen now
you start asking well why why wouldn't
Venus conve um and it turns out a better
question is why on Earth is Earth's core
convecting because when you start doing
the map when you start looking at how
much heat you would need to have
escaping the Earth to generate a
magnetic field and you look at how much
heat could actually have just been
carried by conduction the numbers are
really close um and so we're just like
barely able to conve on Earth and so
Venus might be more than Norm Venus
might be the planet that's kind of
cooling at a just below the rate that
would result in convection the fact that
Earth also has PL
tectonics tends to be really important
as a cooling mechanism for the planet so
imagine if you're trying to cool a cake
um or let's say you have a baked potato
this is my favorite if you have baked
potato you could just let it sit there
and cool through conduction or you can
try to cut it up so that the interior
gets exposed and cools down immediately
and play tectonics is kind of like the
cutting up of the potato because you're
constantly exposing new material to the
surface and descending cold material on
the inside so the fact that we have
plate tectonics on Earth might be
ultimately responsible for why we have a
Dynamo generating magnetic field today
because it's a very efficient way to
remove heat from a planet Venus doesn't
have plate tectonics and it's closer to
the sun does that
matter it only the reason we think that
matters is because uh what happened in
the atmosphere so the runaway greenhouse
ultimately removed all the water from
Venus now on Earth yeah we have water on
the surface in our oceans and in our
atmosphere but we also have water inside
the planet and water can actually be
used to lubricate um the plates as they
move around so we think plate tectonics
actually relies on having these volatile
materials like water inside the planet
so it's possible that Venus doesn't have
plate tectonics because it got rid of
its water so quickly um through the
runaway greenhouse of fire so this this
convection conduction distinction is
interesting I want to make sure the
audience gets it so you're saying that
if I have you know a a hot end of an
object and a cold end but it's a very
smooth gradient it's not that much
hotter on one end that much cooler then
you can just transfer that heat by
conduction but if it's a dramatic thing
there's going to be Swirls and
convection absolutely yeah that's that's
a great way to think about it and I like
that I always like to go back to the pot
on the stove right you got your porridge
on the stove or something like that um
if your burner is not on high enough the
temperature difference is not so big the
temp so you don't have to transfer a
bunch of heat through it you can manage
it through conduction but as soon as you
make that temperature high enough at the
bottom then the heat transfers is much
higher and you get the bubbling and the
the moving around and stuff so I'm going
to guess that since Mars is smaller and
further away from the Sun and has less
atmosphere it does not have a liquid
core help me out tell me I'm right so so
we seismology actually told us that Mars
does have a liquid core but again it's
not it's it's again the issue of the
Motions right so again it's the lack of
PL tectonics on Mars uh that doesn't
allow it to transfer whatever heat it
has coming out but it's also very true
that it's cooler nowadays so even if it
had play tectonics it's unclear if there
would still be enough heat transferred
to allow convective motions in the core
okay so liquid but no convection as far
as we know exactly all right good and
then there's like this radical change I
I was when when I was a kid I always
like theoretical physics but in my
family's world that was just astronomy
so they would get me these astronomy
books and so I was a huge believer that
there used to be a planet in between
Mars and Jupiter that got destroyed or
something but that's not right uh we
just go out there and we have the gas
giants and and what you told me earlier
was that there's more heter
heterogeneity there than we originally
thought yeah absolutely so it's
interesting to think about sort of our
textbook model of what happens inside
say Jupiter right you picture Jupiter as
being this mostly hydrogen gas ball and
probably has some sort of Rocky core at
the center if you think about how
planets form people usually talk about
that Rocky core being about 10 Earth
masses in size that's when it got big
enough that it could attract all the gas
in the early solar system to become this
Giant gas planet um but then the Juno
Mission got to Jupiter and through very
careful gravity measurements inside uh
the planet was able to determine that
it's not just this like Center of rock
and then this fluffy atmosphere around
it instead a lot of it is much more
mixed inside so there's almost like this
gradient this this uh decreasing amount
of rock as you go further and further
out of the planet so we talk about this
now as Jupiter having this fuzzy core
it's not just this like sharp boundary
between the rock layer and the gas layer
instead it's much more mixed and we're
trying to understand how that's possible
and what it means for the formation I
don't even know how to quite visualize
that are there like little Pebbles
floating in the thick atmosphere so this
is one of the hardest things to think
about because we have to take materials
that we're used to how they behave on
surface of Earth and think about what
happens to them when they're millions of
degrees in temperature and millions of
atmospheric pressures uh under that type
of pressure right and it's just
completely different these things are
usually so the hydrogen and the rock is
probably mixed it's probably like a
solution of some sort um it's just
completely different way that materials
behave under really high pressure and
temperature well when you say rock do
you mean solid or are you talking about
the constituents yeah I think I'm pretty
much talking about the constituents more
you're talking about magnes higher uh
higher density elements higher Mass
elements like magnesium silicate
probably some iron too basically
anything that's not gas not hydrogen and
helium let me put it that way anything
that's not hydrogen and helium for the
center of giant planets we've probably
talked about as rock okay so the fuzzy
core what kind of phase is it in it's
well that's an interesting question like
we're used to on the surface of the
Earth just thinking about liquids solids
and gases but when you go deeper inside
planets it's probably accurate to call
it a fluid it's not really a liquid it's
not a gas it's not a plasma it's in that
weird phase space where um the
properties of the material can behave
very differently have we sent probes
just diving into Jupiter to see how long
they last we have so we sent one probe
into Jupiter with the galile
Omission uh it I can't remember how far
deep it went but very much just the
outer part of the atmosphere right again
just like it's hard to to dig inside the
earth it's hard to go under high
pressures inside gas giant planets as
well but we actually it was a really
interesting probe because the goal one
of the main goals of it was to measure
the amount of water in the atmosphere of
Jupiter because water on Earth for
example is so important to determine the
what happens in our atmosphere in in
terms of Storms and things like that and
it just so happened to descend in
Jupiter in like the driest spot in
Jupiter's atmosphere so we measured like
no water whatsoever uh too bad so you
know things happen uh but yeah so there
was also uh this is why probes can be so
important though because they can give
us kind of like real
Inu uh data from a particular region but
you you generally want a lot of them or
more than just one spot so that you can
get S some sort of more General
understanding of the planet is there any
Prospect for a probe that will sort of
Dive In in but then come back out uh not
for the giant planets no maybe the the
closest analogy to that it's not a pro
but and but it also happens to be my
favorite mission to think about in the
future uh is the dragonfly Mission
that's planned to go to the Moon Titans
so Saturn has this Moon Titan very cool
Moon um and one of the amazing things
about the moon is it has a atmosphere
very similar to Earth's in the sense
that it's mostly nitrogen and the
pressure at the surface is about one
point 1.5 bars so 1.5 the pressure of
Earth's atmosphere okay so in that sense
Titan's atmosphere is very much like
Earth it's much colder planet
um but the other cool thing about the
fact that it's a moon it's small its
gravity is really low yeah so dense
atmosphere and low gravity means it's
really easy to fly so we are sending an
octo copper something with basically
eight helicopter blades that is going to
land on the surface of Titan do a bunch
of science at a particular location then
fly up again look for somewhere new to
land go travel to that spot land again
do a bunch of more science and do a
bunch of these uh kind of traverses
across the surface of Titan so it's the
first mission where we'll have more than
we'll have inc2 information at more than
one location over a large distance right
we aren't talking about Rover small
Rover distances like on Mars we're
talking about hundreds of kilometers of
travel on the surface because the the
atmosphere is thicker than Mars so it's
easier to fly exactly yeah when is this
basically put you could put cardboard on
your arms and flap them and you could
fly on Titan there's probably other
obstacles to doing that but yes that
sounds that's very evocative so when is
this scheduled to occur so good question
so the mission is in development right
now probably launching sometime in the
next decade uh that it takes patient
some amount of years to get there and so
for so you know I would I would be
thinking late 2030s by the time we're
this will kind of send us back data that
will be really cool and even though
we've had a pretty good track record of
late with things like this it's always
possible the thing just fails
right I mean I'm scared to say it yes of
course it's always possible that
something could fail um but the
scientists who are working on this um it
it's always amazing to me how many of
the missions that we send out the planet
succeed the way they do because there's
so much that could go wrong but there's
so much work done to really ensure that
nothing goes wrong right so so it's it's
quite amazing to me the feat of the
engineering and science that goes into
every single Mission we send up so back
to back to Jupiter I know that um
there's metallic hydrogen taking up a
lot of Jupiter and liquid metallic
hydrogen and so is that like a little
fun part of the inner structure or is
that most of Jupiter that is most of
Jupiter so again great this kind of a
great example of hydrogen what we think
of as hydrogen on Earth just as Gap you
might expect put it under enough
pressure it becomes a metal so it's
actually a really good electrical
conductor and this happens at about
let's say um about six or 7,000
kilometers deep so about 10 you go 10%
into the planet and poop you get this
phase transition you're in metallic
hydrogen now metallic hydrogen's great
electrical conductor that's what's
generating Jupiter's magnetic field so
rather than a liquid iron core in
Jupiter Genera the magnetic field you've
got this giant metallic uh region inside
Jupiter generating its immense magnetic
field that we
see so good that's a a success story for
the theory and experiment uh combining
with that it all fits together and the
other thing that I maybe this is not
fair because you're a interior of the
planet person but I'm always amazed at
how colorful and stripy Jupiter is like
why hasn't it all just mixed together by
now yeah this is a great question first
of all I love the fact that the color so
hydrogen's a clear gas yeah so if
Jupiter were pure hydrogen we wouldn't
see any colors at all exact all the
colors we see are from like tiny bits of
kind of pollution I would say like in
the in the atmosphere of these things
like ammonia and sulfur and stuff like
this that are floating around that we
can see um the stripy is really great
and because it shows us an important
concept that we that's hard for us to
kind of um put our minds around and
that's that's the fact that rotation is
really good at kind of separating
regions inside a fluid so if you spin a
fluid it's really hard to get it to mix
on the inside and this is a result of
the forces that occur the Coriolis
forces and how they affect um fluids so
the fact that we have these bands these
stripy bands is almost a direct result
of the fact that we have spinning fluids
and they don't mix when they're spinning
that fast and just so people know
Jupiter's spinning really fast Jupiter's
spinning really fast day on Jupiter is
what it's like 10 hours or something
something like that so it's it's much
bigger than the earth so that's very
fast indeed yeah and yeah I Jupiter was
always my favorite planet I would like
to go visit Jupiter someday but then
there's Saturn which is you know
comparable in some ways but very
different in others it doesn't have
quite the colorful shy bands that
Jupiter does yeah Saturn's interesting
because although it doesn't have as many
observable bands it does have these we
saw with the Cassini Mission it has
these amazing storms at the pole so this
hexagonal feature I don't know if you've
seen this this storm at the poles right
and so there's these great kind of fluid
waves that are occurring to cause that
pattern the winds on Jupiter are
actually very fast it's just that
they're not as stripey there's not as
many of the bands that go around the
planet you said Jupiter sorry but Saturn
again right giant planet a little bit
smaller than Jupiter still has metallic
hydrogen on the inside generating a
Dynamo and a magnetic seal um the rings
on the outside the amazing thing about
Saturn to me is is that you've got these
gorgeous rings and we can you know you
can see them in a telescope but there
are waves in those rings that are
actually caused by motions inside Saturn
itself so we can use the Rings as a
probe of motions going on inside Saturn
and what do we learn from those waves so
yeah what we've learned from that is
that the innermost part of Saturn is
actually what we call stably stratified
it doesn't have this convective
motioning happening in the deepest part
of Saturn because there are these
gravity WS kind of like what you expect
when you see like the surface of um like
the ocean or whatever kind of move up
and down there are these gravity waves
but it's not circulating like convecting
motions are so that's one thing we
learned from the Rings I know that
there's an attempt in some C circles to
police the language of gravity waves
versus gravitational waves gravitational
waves we detect from black holes in
spiraling but gravity waves are motions
in planetary Interiors yeah I can tell
you that as someone who kind of did grew
up kind of doing physics and astronomy
and planetary science that was very
confusing to all very very different
things but otherwise Saturn and Jupiter
kind of related to each other
qualitatively yeah qualitatively
Saturn's a bit smaller so the pressures
are a bit lower inside the temperatures
are a bit lower but a lot of the same
the physics is the same but then Uranus
and Neptune are actually kind of
different yeah Uranus and Neptune are
seem to be completely different beasts
so they seem to be what would have
happened if you had while you were
building Jupiter and Saturn but you
didn't get big enough fast enough to
attract a bunch of gas so instead you've
got these um Rocky icy balls left with a
little bit of gas on top they're we
think they're mostly stuff like water um
although it's really hard to actually
figure out what goes on deep inside
these these planetary bodies their
magnetic fields are completely different
than any of the other planets in the
solar system so rather than having this
nice dipolar field like we have on earth
with like a North Pole and a South Pole
they're multi-polar they have a bunch of
North and South Poles all over the place
um so we spend a lot of time trying to
understand why that is uh but also it's
a great kind of um test bed for what
happens to water when it's under really
high pressure and temperature and you
get really cool new phases of water you
get something called super ionic water
where the oxygen atoms become a lattice
and the hydrogen atoms just flow through
the oxygen just really weird stuff
happens at high pressure and temperature
when you have water and is this from
data or from Theory so it started to be
from Theory but very recently in the
past say five years we actually now have
experiments uh that can take materials
at some of our biggest um uh particle
colliders and you you basically hit a
material with a big shock wave uh and
boom you put it on a really high
pressure temperature and we've actually
created super iic water in Labs here on
Earth no and I know that I forget
whether it's purely hypothetical for
exoplanets or or even for our outer
planets but people love the idea of
diamonds in the planets right uh either
you know Diamond rain or icebergs or
something like that is that a Uranus and
Neptune phenomenon so that could be a
Uranus and Neptune phenomena so here's
the thing in addition to water there are
things like methane CH4 right so carbon
based elements out there and so you
start asking what happens to vh4 when
you put it under high pressure and we
know about the diamond um phase of
carbon even here on Earth you put carbon
under enough pressure you're G to get
diamond uh and so that's likely to
happen inside Neptune and Uranus as well
the question is does anything weird kind
of happen and it turns out that if you
go if we understand the the exact
mixture of like say water ammonia
methane inside the giant planets like
Uranus and Neptune the carbon could
actually separate out from the other
materials and it's heavier so it could
sink and so there's a theory of out
there that you would actually have a
diamond sea kind of in the Deep interior
of Uranus and Neptune and an interesting
thing about Diamond is at the melting
point it has the same property that
water does at the surface of the Earth
where the solid phase is a little bit
less dense than the liquid phase and so
you could have Diamond icebergs on the
Diamond Sea that float on it just like
water icebergs or float on our ocean so
some interesting things to think about
what might be happening in Yus epton and
also on exoplanet is that um right below
a sort of gaseous layer so that might be
below a gas layer but also below like a
water layer a mixture of things like
water ammonium methane but just certain
pressures and temperatures where
suddenly stuff separates out so you're
talking about I would I mean we don't
know exactly the depth of this but let's
say rough think about roughly halfway
through the planet or so this is going
to wreak havoc with the world's Diamond
markets once we actually start
Excavating these icebergs you'd think so
but let's be honest here we can actually
make diamonds in Labs nowadays the only
reason diamonds are expensive is because
people are trying to stop them from
being made in labs and to go make them
something that's hard to get that's
right no reason to where ear ancep to
get diamonds we could just make them in
labs and sell them for a buck each again
I don't think you're maximizing your uh
Grand money potential here uh by by
telling the truth about uh diamonds so
well I mean then I guess we should give
a shout out to all the little tiny
things in the solar system whether it's
dwarf planets like Pluto or asteroids or
hyperb objects etc etc there's an
enormous array of different kinds of
ways that matter comes together in our
solar system absolutely and I love the
small bodies in the solar system I
absolutely love because they're
basically the ingredients that created
the planets and so imagine you know
imagine you you make a bunch of cookies
for example and you show up at someone
or someone else did and you show up at
their house and they're like here A
bunch of cookies eat some and you'd like
to know what they're made of because
maybe you have an allergy yeah um but
they don't for some reason they don't
tell you right one way you could figure
out what they're made of is by looking
at kind of the remnants of stuff left on
the counter where they were just made so
you might see some sugar floating around
somewhere some some butter stuck on the
counter or whatever right and that's
exactly what the asteroids and comets
and kyber Bel objects are they're are
leftover ingredients of Planet formation
and so we can really learn a lot about
how Earth and the other planets formed
by studying these leftovers and comets I
presume also which have a lot of the
and is it true that Comet collisions
contributed to a lot of the atmospheres
the interner planets so that's a good
question we don't the short answer is we
don't know we do know that comets have a
lot of water and that comets end up on
these weird orbits sometimes that could
bring them to the inner solar system so
they can deliver water to planets but
when we look at um something called the
the data H ratio of comet so how much of
the two isotopes of hydrogen and H2O in
water um um the dyum isotope the heavier
isotope uh there's like a particular
signature that our oceans have of this D
ratio that tells you something about
where our water is from right and um it
doesn't really match exactly what com
the ones we comments we've gone to when
we look at their ratios weren't the same
so it might be a mixture it might be a
little bit of comet it might be a little
bit of some asteroids that we know also
have some water and it might be that a
lot of our oceans and stuff just
actually came from water that was able
to be stored inside of Earth that
essentially got out gas from volcanoes
for example so there's still lots of
learning to be done when it comes to the
solar system and I guess this is we
haven't even had a chance to talk about
the other 100 billion planetary systems
or whatever in our galaxy but what what
is the what is the current you know Vibe
amongst people who think about
exoplanets on the one hand very exciting
we've we've found all these planets that
we're going to find a a whole bunch more
on the other hand we've kind of been
humbled at
how different our predictions were than
what we've actually seen so where are we
kind of Landing right now yeah 100%
agree with you and I think what this is
is a major opportunity because now it
used to be the case that if you wanted
to come up with a theory for something
on Earth you'd say okay how can I test
this Theory well we can't build another
Earth and and test it see if it happened
there so we'd have to look at the other
planets in our solar system and if we
had a good explanation about you know if
if Earth has X then y must happen it
better also explain why some other
planet that has X also had y happen um
but you only have eight other planets
and some or seven other planets and some
other uh small bodies and stuff but now
we've got these thousands of exoplanets
out there and it's just an incredible
test bed for all the theories that we
use to develop for how our own solar
system and our own Earth formed so I
think it's an immense opportunity and it
means that we have a lot of learning to
do about what's possible well your
research career spans this era where we
found all these planets I mean what is
the single most surprising thing to you
that we've learned so
far oh gosh
um single most surprising thing I yeah I
don't know if anything is I think the
hot find that first um exoplanet
orbiting sort of a a a live star uh this
giant hot Jupiter so close to the that
was a major surprise right I think for
everyone I not just me right but
um and the fact that it showed us how
much planetary migration really matters
that planets can move around I think
that's still the most surprise and you
know we always get down to the end of
the podcast where we let our hair down
and have fun so life on these other
planets uh what are your
prospects uh so someone the other day
asked me if I had to bet what planet
would or object would we find life on
next and I went with Titan Titan so this
Moon of Saturn as the place we're most
likely to find life if it's out there so
the key thing here is you think about as
far as what we know about how life
formed on Earth where are the
ingredients and the conditions right for
it to happen so you're looking for a
place turns out that liquid water seems
to be important having an energy source
for the life seems to be important
having complex molecules around that can
uh use that energy source along with the
Catalyst environment of liquid water um
to build larger and larger molecules and
the place where that all seems to be
there is on Titan so you've got water
this water ocean underneath the surface
of Titan You've Got U a surface that's
basically formed out of hydrocarbon so
it's a bunch of Organics on the surface
uh and you have energy sources from from
tidal interactions and so forth on the
interior so I'm guessing we find it at
Titan any chance for life on the diamond
ocean of
Neptune uh if so we're talking about
life that can live at much higher
temperatures and pressures than anything
we have found on the earth so it's
probably something that we wouldn't
fully understand but would be cool if it
was there that's what makes it exciting
looking forward to what happens next so
Sab Stanley thanks so much for being on
the mindscape podcast thanks for having
me
[Music]
here
la